the cruise ship floating off the
California coast with 21 coronavirus
patients onboard will dock later today
in Oakland California
anyone who tested positive will
immediately disembark and then head to
the hospital for treatment all right the
other 3,500 people on board will go to
military posts in California in Texas
and Georgia for testing and a 14 day
quarantine the process is expected to
last several days so let's bring in 70
Christian White House press secretary
communications director Stephanie are
you comfortable with these with these
moves or as they are as the federal
government asked to be comfortable with
California's moves good morning
we've been working really hard the task
force led by a vice president pence of
course has been working really hard with
state and local officials so you know
we're going to get that ship we're
working hard to get that ship home and
as you said we want to get the most
vulnerable off first and everybody into
quarantine and test it as appropriate we
heard some of the news from the task
force over the weekend was like you know
if you're older maybe you shouldn't
think about going on a cruise things
like that
how close is the federal government to
having actual travel warnings regarding
you know at what age should you not find
an airplane if you've got an underlying
condition at what age should you
consider not taking a cruise things like
that well the task force is meeting
every single day and they have been
giving daily briefings the president is
briefed every day of course right now
we're just we're telling people to act
as if this is a severe flu season and
you know wash your hands often and if
you are elderly or if you have any
ailments then you know underlying health
issues maybe don't go to areas where
there's big crowds if you do start to
feel sick stay home don't go to work
stay out of that right now those are the
the warnings that we're giving people
and then we'll go from there we'll see
what happens as this continues Stephanie
when when Bernie was on Meet the Press
over the weekend Chuck Todd asked him if
he was going to continue to be on the
campaign trail because we keep hearing
if you're around 80 years old you're
susceptible and he is 78 years old
President Trump is 73 will he continue
to have rallies and be out there on the
campaign trail he actually just
addressed this yes he plans on still
holding
and I'll tell you what with our
president this man who doesn't sleep and
who I have seen work 15 16 hours a day
every day I have no problem thinking
that he's gonna be just fine and just
healthy yeah what about the fact that
apparently there was a guy at CPAC and
he tested positively and he apparently
shook hands with Ted Cruz and Ted Cruz
is now going into self quarantine for a
full 14 days apparently he shook hands
with Matt slap and Matt slap shook hands
with the president is the president a
little freaked out about that no not at
all again this is something that is like
a flu and so people are taking the the
appropriate precautions the President of
the United States as we all know is a
quite a hand washer he's his hand
sanitizer all the time so he's not
concerned about this at all I know Ted
Cruz and I know congressman Gosar both
doing self quarantine you know you don't
know who each individual person is
around all of the time so perhaps
they've got constituents who are a
little bit older etc so I think that's
why they're making those those
responsible choices so Connecticut
senator Murphy is the new Adam Schiff he
goes on all the shows and just plays
politics and here's an example he goes
we have a president who is lying to the
American people that the vaccine was two
months away and that everybody could get
a test if they wanted a test he has to
be straight with the American people
he's making everything worse what's your
reaction to that you know I've said this
before the president said this before as
well I just want to stress to
politicians and the media to stop using
this as a tool to politicize things and
to scare people it's not responsible
this is not the time for this people
need to be looking to the CDC for
guidance
people need to be again washing their
hands treating this like a flu making
responsible choices this is absolutely
not the time to be trying to scare
people to gain political points or to
get headlines all right let's talk a
little bit about you know in the last
year a lot of Americans have heard more
about FISA the Foreign Intelligence of
the FISA law are going to expire unless
there's a let's make a deal moment in
Congress what does the president want
and how close is a deal
well I'm not gonna get ahead of how
close we are with a deal but the
president has said time and again and I
couldn't agree more that this should
never happen to any candidate ever again
any president ever again there have been
fights of court judges who have come out
publicly saying that those warrants
should have never been done so I think
that the president is looking for a
bipartisan effort to try and stop that
from happening so it is the closer
because Democrats just say leave it and
Lindsey Graham so it wants some wants to
continue it but want some changes we
know we've had a lot of people on here
from mark Meadows your new chief of
staff on down saying they want some
changes is there a sense the president
wants to scrap it altogether no I think
again I think the president wants a
bipartisan effort here I think that
there's definitely some changes that
absolutely need to be made and I think
once he feels satisfied that what
happened to him and what happened to his
campaign will not happen to another
president or or nominee and I would say
Democrat or Republican then I think that
will move forward
all right Hillary has been interviewed a
lot lately and then there's that Hulu
documentary on her four-part series
she was also interviewed on CNN listen
to what she said about women and the
double standard the double standard
particularly in public life and not only
in political public life but business
life the life of the media and the arts
and so much else yes there is some
absolute misogyny that certainly lives
online but there still is something
inside that when a woman says wait a
minute I'd like to lead I'd like to be
in charge I'd like to be your president
or your chief executive or whatever it
might be
little alarm bells little unconscious
alarm bells start to ring do you agree
with that no I don't and I think that
actually she's minimizing women with
those comments
you know actually under this president
women are doing better than ever
especially with jobs and I would say
just personally at the White House he's
got so many women in leadership at the
White House women are doing great and I
think that to play that card and to
publicize that card actually minimizes
does the operative opposite effect of
what I think she was trying to do so the
president is going to not attend the st.
Patrick's Day lunch and it's the first
time a president hasn't attended I think
in decades really because of the
presence of Nancy Pelosi and if I could
paraphrase she basically he basically
thinks she's been dividing the country
is is it worth missing an event because
of Nancy Pelosi's presence yeah I think
that I think that right now he's got a
lot of work to do he's got briefings on
the coronavirus we'll be doing our own
thing at the White House for st.
Patrick's Day
I think it's exactly true we don't need
to deal with any more of her you know
little games and her little ripping up
of paper who knows what she's got
planned for this and that's not what the
country should be focused on is her
games in her politics so president's
going to stay at the White House and
work on behalf of the American people
okay so he won't be attending the
speaker's lunch her deputy chief of
staff put out a statement and said
there's never been stronger support in
the Congress and in the country for the
u.s. Ireland bilateral relationship one
would think that the White House could
set petty partisan politics aside for
this historic occasion what do you think
of that I find that to be laughable
absolutely laughable and his not
attending a lunch does not mean that
anything with that with Northern Ireland
is anything less than great all right
very good
Stephanie Grisham joining us today from
West Palm Beach down in Florida with the
president Stephanie thank you